foreign
today we will learn how to create heat
maps in Excel but before we begin if
you're a tech geek in a continuous hunt
for latest technological Trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and don't forget to hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn also if you're an
aspiring business analyst looking for
online training and certifications from
prestigious universities in
collaboration with feeding experts then
search no more simply launch
postgraduate program and business
analysis from Toyota University in
collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft should be your right choice
for more details use the link in the
description box below with that in mind
let's get started we have started the
Microsoft Excel on my screen you can see
a small data set the data set is about
students and their marks in the six
semesters right now we should be
creating a new heat map to describe
their rankings Now to create a heat map
the procedure is really simple just Ctrl
a select the entire data data go to the
Home tab and there you can see the style
screw and in the Styles group click on
the conditional formatting now out of
all the options go to the color scales
and when you open the color scales you
can see some types of maps select the
green yellow red Scale map which should
show Green for highest yellow for
mediate and red for low right this is
how you create a heat map just select
the first option and there you go the
heat map has been successfully generated
the green colored cells indicate the
highest marks orange and yellow color
indicate the intermediate marks or the
average marks and the red color
indicates the lowest marks that's how
you create heat maps in Excel we have
reached the end of this session on how
to create heat maps in Excel but before
we end the video let's take a minute to
hear it from our Learners about their
success story after graduating from the
business analyst Pro graduate program by
simply learn from Purdue University in
collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft
I have always been passionate about
learning new things and improving my
teaching skills about five years ago I
realized that I have a gap in my
knowledge and to fill the Gap I needed
to skill myself I chose simply learning
at my upskilling partner because of all
it's comprehensive curriculum and it's
connection with Purdue University hi my
name is Carlos vinares
I live in Lexington in the city of
Kentucky in the United States I am an
assistant professor at Midway University
and I hold a PhD in management human
resources and Leadership I decided to
opt for the post graduation program in
business analysis from civilian which
has helped me a lot my professional and
personal life I have been teaching
having before I moved to the United
States years ago
I try to use Excel while teaching
research classes
but
since I only had the basic knowledge
about it and other business intelligence
tools it was very difficult for me at
the beginning but after completing this
class and learning how to use tools like
Excel Tableau power bi power query
problem I feel like it has been a total
game changer for me now I apply these
skills everywhere
which has also helped me a lot in my
yearly review I submitted all my
certificates to my university and based
on that my University plans to develop a
class focus on business analysis and
starting in fall 2023.
and I am really excited
when I finally decide to go for an
online program I research a lot
and finally I chose simply learner and I
must say it has been a wonderful
experience
if you see how the business work is
changing now and you're Skilling
yourself is quite essential to keep up
with the change everything works on
numbers now data is more valuable and
important than ever so
I encourage you to keep learning
and keep growing and with that we have
come to an end of this session on how to
create heat Maps if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
this session or if you require the
resources like PPT and dataset that we
used in the session please feel free to
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of experts will be more
than happy to resolve all your queries
at the earliest until next time thank
you stay safe keep learning and get
ahead
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here